mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalkar
solve for the value of each color in the
following arithmetic problem
each color represents a different digit
from zero to nine
i think lucas for suggesting this
problem
it originally appeared as a belgian
olympiad problem with the letters m a
and t
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
we'll get started by focusing on the
letter m
suppose m equals 5.
in that case the sum will be at least
1500
and this is going to be too large of a
value because we need the sum to be 14
16.
therefore m equals 5 produces a sum
that's too large and it's not possible
the same logic is true for m greater
than or equal to 5. we can eliminate all
of these possibilities
what if m equals 3
in that case the largest value of the
sum will be 1197
and that's too small because we need the
sum to be 14 16. therefore m equals 3
cannot be a possibility and m less than
or equal to 3 can also be eliminated
what remains is m is equal to 4.
this will simplify our calculation if we
substitute m is equal to 4 we know that
just from the terms involving m we get a
sum of 1204
if we subtract those out we get the
resulting sum of
212 and we have a new problem
we now need to solve for a and t
let's focus on t
in the units column t plus t can either
equal 2 or it can equal 12. consider the
first case
if t plus t equals 2 then t is equal to
1 which then means the entire problem
has to be 10a plus 10a plus 1 plus 11 is
equal to
this means 20a equals 200 and a is equal
to 10
but that's not possible because a has to
be a single digit from 0 to 9.
therefore we must have t plus t is equal
to 12. this means t is equal to six and
we can then go ahead and solve that a
must be equal to seven
therefore this is the answer to the
problem
m is equal to four a is equal to seven
and t is equal to six and we can in fact
verify this does work out
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube
as always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]
you